new information emerges on coronaviruses
countries around the world lockdown the
u.s. ramps up its own response and China
tries to avoid the consequences of its
own evil government I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the men Shapiro show is sponsored by
Express VPN your data is your business
protected at Express at VPN comm slash
pen we're gonna get to all the news in
just one seconds and as always plenty of
news there is as always just gonna
remind you we are all in this together
even if we are apart don't worry we're
gonna make it through this there won't
be an end to this we're going to talk
about when that end might come what the
projections are for how long this lasts
what the measures are that are gonna be
taken how long those will last because
right now there's a lot of uncertainty
out there a lot of misinformation out
there we can get into it when you break
all of the town but first let's talk
about a simple fact the markets are up
and down and up and down and all around
and up and down the markets today are
already smashing down through the 20,000
barrier which of course is not a great
shock because there's so much
uncertainty in the economy right now we
don't know when these measures are going
to be alleviated we don't know how long
people are gonna be at home we don't
know how many millions of jobs are gonna
be lost throughout all this now might be
a good time to take some of your money
you have lying around the house and
invest that in some gold precious metals
are doing really well right now why
because uncertainty means that gold is a
safe haven for your money what exactly
are you waiting for a hedge against what
we've seen in the past few weeks I mean
it's been insane right few weeks ago the
stock market is at 30,000 now it's down
below 20,000 it's down 10% one day then
it's up 12% and then it's down 15% it's
all over the place if you're looking for
a place to put your money that is at
least going to not be worth zero you
might want to take a look at some
precious of metals if you haven't yet
taken the first step of requesting a
free information can on gold you should
know this is not a complicated process
with my friends over at Birch gold call
Birch gold right now convert your
traditional IRA or 401k into a precious
metals IRA if that is something you are
interested in Birch gold will go to work
and make things super simple for you
they'll have a conversation with you you
can determine if precious metals make
sense for you
I'm not saying liquidate all your stock
when the markets down I'm saying that
you should at least be diversified if
you'd been diversified before you'd be
in better shape now than if you had all
of your money in the stock market
there's no obligation so you have
nothing to lose to take that first step
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Better Business Bureau again reality
speaking you should have some money in
precious metals don't wait until the
market drops again to protect your
hard-earned savings text Ben - 47 47 47
today see how simple and straightforward
the move can be for you again text Ben -
47 47
47 I do not take investment lightly
needed neither to the folks in perch
cold ask all your questions get your
answers text Ben - 47 47 47 so let us
begin with some new information on
coronavirus one of the reasons the
market is up and down and all around is
because we have no idea what's going on
nobody knows anything okay that is the
theme of today's show nobody knows
anything except that the Chinese
government is gonna have to be punished
at some point for the evil they've
inflicted on this planet and it is grave
and it is ridiculous we'll get to the
Chinese virus it is the Chinese virus it
doesn't mean it has anything to do with
Chinese people it doesn't have anything
to do with racism or ethnicity it has to
do with an awful evil Communist Chinese
virus okay the fact is this thing would
not have been unleashed on the globe if
it had not been for the malfeasance
and evil action of the Chinese
government which has been a crap show
since the revolution that male brought
into place okay that this is just an
evil government and the fact that we
have not treated it as such is one of
the reasons we are now seeing the
results that we are seeing globally
today yeah we ought to be treating them
as the global as the global threat that
they are and that means taking them a
lot more seriously than we have
heretofore when we are out of this thing
there need to be consequences
for the Chinese government serious
consequences for the Chinese government
we'll get to that a little bit later on
in the show but first well bring you
some of these sort of miasma of
information that is floating around so
there's some good news and there's some
bad news and there are all sorts of
different estimates as to the path the
trajectory that this coronavirus is
going to take Sharon Begley has an
interesting piece today over at stat
news com talking about the death rates
now I had suggested a couple of weeks
ago the death rates were going to be
lower for coronavirus then we're calm
then we're being bandied about the World
Health Organization had originally
suggested a three point four percent
death rate for those inflicted with
coronavirus I said at the time this is
way too high the diamond princess Cruz
did not evidence that kind of death rate
even though you had 700 people in
extraordinarily close quarters it didn't
evidence 70 percent infection rate it
didn't evidence at three point four
percent death right okay well now we are
finding that even in wuhan province
where this thing started those are not
the death rates Sharon Begley writes in
a rare piece of good news about Kovan 19
a team of infectious disease experts
calculates that the fatality rate and
people who have symptoms of the disease
caused by the new corona virus is about
1.4 percent which is really high right I
mean that is a lot higher than for
example the seasonal flu which is about
0.1%
although that estimate applies
specifically to Wu hen the Chinese city
where the outbreak began and is based on
data from there it offers the guide to
the rest of the world where many
countries might see even lower
rates the new figure is significantly
below earlier estimates of two percent
or three percent well below the death
rate for China they send simply dividing
deaths by cases which yields almost four
percent it's still higher than the 0.1%
death rate from seasonal flu as I
mentioned but it does raise hopes that
the worst consequence of the corona
virus will still remain uncommon now
cutting against that optimism because no
one was immune to the new virus the
majority of the population will be
infected absent the quick arrival of
vaccine or drastic public health
interventions such as closing public
places and cancelling public events
those same scientists conclude in a
paper submitted to a journal but not yet
peer-reviewed so there been these
estimates floating around that anywhere
from forty to seventy percent of the
population may eventually get the corona
virus eventually being the key word
there because if that happens over the
course of a couple of years well then
that is not actually a health emergency
it's just a bad situation
health emergencies everybody gets that
within the next two months right then we
are just swamped that's when that that
bell curve moves over the line and the
line representing the amount of medical
capacity that we as a society have but
if that is spaced out over the course of
the next couple of years then it just
becomes a really really horrible
seasonal flu that takes a lot of people
from us but is not beyond our capacity
to contain to a certain extent the
expectation that a majority of the
population will become infected reflects
a worst case scenario about who
encounter assume something model or is
called homogeneous mixing but even more
realistic assumption that not everyone
mixes with everyone else means at least
a quarter to a half of the population
will very likely become infected absent
social distancing measures or a vaccine
according to Joseph Wu and Kathleen lung
of the University of Hong Kong who are
leaders in the modeling of infectious
diseases not as I say there is some
controversy over exactly how long this
thing is going to last and what level of
infection is going to take place and
also this is leaving out the facts the
treatments may in fact get better
without even a vaccine for example
there's an article today in en 24 News
talking about Hydra hydroxychloroquine
which is 8 which I believe is an anti
malarial treatment which is now starting
to be used as a as a treatment for
corona virus early indications according
to E and 24 is that the treatment with
hydroxychloroquine would reduce the load
and the results are even more promising
with hydroxychloroquine and as a throw
myosin an antibiotic effective against
viruses so you might see some some new
results from particular drugs that are
brought to bear that could lower the the
chances of death or severe
act of the virus which of course would
lower the death rate and make it less
dangerous meanwhile there's an open
debate as to how long this thing is
going to last sort of in society
generally because while we are treating
this virus as though it is going to just
be with us basically forever
the hot zone of the virus or the hot
period of the virus it does have a rise
and it does have a fall
hey let yesterday we had an expert from
Johns Hopkins University on the radio
show it would serve in both the Trump
and the Obama administration's and he
said that he thinks the things gonna
peter out by May because there is sort
of a three-month period that we've seen
where the case numbers rise and then
they tend to tail off he says these
viruses tend to start off very hot and
then they seem to cool down a little bit
so there are some alarmist reports today
about how easily it is how easy it is to
transmit that's true it's one of the
reasons why we're engaging in social
distancing it's one of the reasons why
we are all staying home for the moment
we'll get to some different responses
from different countries in just a
second cuz it is sort of a fascinating
social experiment to see how different
countries are treating coronavirus and
what measures they are taking but
according to the New York Times
coronavirus can live for three days on
some surfaces like plastic and steel
according to new research is one of the
reasons why gyms have been shut down
experts say the risk of consumers
getting infected from touching those
materials is still low although they
offered additional warnings about how
long the virus survives in air which may
have important implications for medical
workers the new study published Tuesday
in the New England Journal of Medicine
also suggested the virus disintegrates
over the course of a day on cardboard
lessening the worries that deliveries
will spread the virus during this period
of staying and working from home when
the virus become suspended and droplets
smaller than five micrometers like
aerosols it can say stay suspended for
about half an hour before drifting down
and settling on surfaces where it can
linger for hours the finding on aerosol
is inconsistent with the with the World
Health Organization's position that the
virus is not transported by air that
would mean that it's a lot more easy to
transmit if it's just hanging around in
the air after somebody sneezes for
example the virus lives longest on
plastic and steel it can survive for up
to 72 hours but the amount of viable
virus decreases sharply over this time
it also does poorly on copper surviving
for about four hours on cardboard it can
survive up to 24 hours which suggests
the packages that arrived in the mail
should have only low levels of the virus
unless the delivery person coughs or
sneezed on it or handled it with
contaminated hands which is true in
general unless the people handling any
of this stuff or sick the actual risk of
getting infected is incredibly
so you know there there are P I mean I
know somebody who's immunocompromised
and every time they have a package come
in their house they immediately wash it
down with sort of a solution of diluted
bleach if you're if you're really you
know paranoid about the stuff or if you
have an underlying health condition if
you're elderly that might be something
to consider at this point now with all
of that said they're wildly varying
estimates on how durable this virus is
going to be over the course of time
which of course is the big question the
reason the market dropped today and the
reason the markets are gonna continue to
drop is because the market excuse me is
trying to don't worry we disinfect
everything here people are far away from
me I'm alone in the studio guys when I
cough no one's getting dead okay so the
but when we when we talk about the when
we talk about the path that this virus
is taking they're these widely variant
estimates so for example there was an
Israeli Nobel laureate named Michael
Levitt he won the 2013 Nobel Prize in
Chemistry he's praising Israel Israel
has taken preventative measures they've
basically locked everybody in their
house he said most people are naturally
immune to the disease he said the
infection rate in China is slowing down
so the end of the pandemic is near he
said that he's an American British
Israeli biophysicist he says that he
crunches that he crunched the numbers
and he said he wrote to his friends in
in whom a province he said when they
answered us describing how complicated
their situation was I decided to take a
deeper look at the numbers in the hope
of reaching some conclusion the rate of
infection of the virus in the whom a
province increased by 30 percent each
day which is a scary statistic he said
I'm not an influenza expert but I can
analyze numbers that his exponential
growth had the growth continued at that
rate the whole world would have been
coming infected within 90 days but as
love it continued to process the numbers
the pattern changed on February 1st when
he first looked at the stats whom a
province had 1800 new cases a day by
February 6th the number had reached 4700
new cases a day On February 7th
something changed he said the number of
new infections started to drop linearly
and did not stop a week later the same
happened with the number of deaths this
dramatic change in the curve of marked
the median points and enable better
prediction of one the pandemic and based
on that I concluded that the situation
in all of China will improve within two
weeks and indeed now they're very new in
there very few new infection cases now
as we'll see maybe the Chinese
government is just lying about all of
that maybe there are new infection cases
in China but by best available data
which is the data that was presented to
Leavitt he says this thing will slow and
stop within weeks Leavitt likened the
trends diminishing interest
Tracy says if a person receives a 30%
interest rate on their savings on day
one a 29% rate on day two and so on
you understand that eventually you're
not gonna earn very much similarly
although new cases are being reported in
China they represent a fraction of those
reported in the early stages he said
even if the interest rate keeps dropping
you can still make money and some you
invested doesn't lessen it Just's Crow's
more slowly when we discuss diseases it
frightens people a lot because they keep
hearing about new cases every day but
the fact that the infection rate is
slowing down means the end of the
pandemic is near Leavitt predicts that
the virus will likely disappear from
China basically entirely by the end of
March so he's not dismissive of the
precautions he says that you still have
to keep the precautions because that is
one of the things that is allowing time
for this thing to burn out he says that
Italy's higher death rate than in places
like China or South Korea is that's due
to the fact that elderly people make up
a greater percentage of the population
also he says Italian culture is very
warm it's telling some very rich social
life this is true and contrary to two
sort of common sense the fact is that
people who actually have richer social
lives are more likely to get this thing
okay so if you were a shut-in now is a
great time to be ashada that's a great
time to be a person who habitually
washed their hands too much in fact is
that Italian culture does have a lot of
cross generational pollination that's
one of the reasons why young people are
bringing the disease to their elderly
grandparents so that is that is one
estimate then you have the estimate from
Ezekiel Emanuel Susan elenberg and
Michael Levy we'll get to that in just
one second because their estimate is
very different and it's this sort of
uncertainty that is leading to the vast
amount of justified unease we'll get to
that in just one moment first you're at
home a lot you're using the internet a
lot now is like the best time ever if
you're a computer hacker if you are a
hacker who's looking for somebody else's
information this is like your dream
everyone is on the internet 24 hours a
day and many of those people are not
using the VPN you should be one of the
people using a VPN or you're doing
something dumb make sure that you are
protecting your Internet activity today
expressvpn encrypts 100% of your data
with the best-in-class encryption so
your information is always protected
even when you're using public Wi-Fi like
at a cafe or hotel you're still
protected expressvpn works on everything
phones laptops routers everyone who
shares your Wi-Fi can still be protected
even if they don't have expressvpn so
protect your online activity today with
the VPN I trust to secure my privacy
visit my special link at expressvpn comm
slash man you get an extra three months
free on one-year package that's expr ESS
VPN
calm / Ben expressvpn calm / Ben to
learn more go check them out right now
protect yourself it's the very least you
can do on the Internet at this time go
check out expressvpn comm / Ben get an
extra three months for free on a
one-year package again it's not gonna
cost you an arm and a leg I know
everybody's a little tight on money but
you got to protect your money by
protecting your credit card number go
check out expressvpn calm right now use
that slash pen get an extra three months
for free on a one-year package okay so
what estimate basically says that in
China this thing's gonna be alleviated
by March considering it started in mid
to late December and alleviated by March
while you'd expect in the United States
is that this thing started in early
March late February you would expect
that presumably March April May that by
May which is exactly what with this
epidemiologist from Johns Hopkins told
me yesterday on the show that that by
May this thing is gonna start to let up
Ezekiel Emanuel Susan elenberg and
Michael levy these are all these are all
various doctors Emmanuel's and
oncologists and medical ethicist Ellen
Berg's biostatistician dr. levy is an
epidemiologist at University of
Pennsylvania they have a piece titled
the corona virus is here to stay so what
happens next and they say that there may
be variant rounds of social distancing
and business shutdowns and all the rest
by the way worth noting it is kind of
weird to hear this sort of stuff from
Ezekiel Emanuel who wrote a piece in the
Atlantic what five six years ago during
the Obama administration talking about
how he would like to die at age 80 the
virus is killing mainly people who are
above the age of 70 so suddenly C
kill'uh manual is having second thoughts
about the whole everyone about the 80s
who just died routine in any case this
piece in the New York Times says in the
last few days most Americans even
President Trump have come to terms with
the need for social distancing though
they feel fine they're staying home and
Avella peg new routines killing time
baking binge watching figuring out how
to homeschool their kids and took far
too long for Americans to accept how
serious coronavirus says now that we've
finally taken the necessary measures in
many places to close schools offices
restaurants and other businesses people
are asking how soon will it all be over
two weeks four weeks when can we go back
to normal
they say unfortunately normal is a long
way off we need to be thinking in terms
of months not weeks we need to stop
picturing that ubiquitous flatten the
curve chart and start imagining a roller
coaster
they say social distancing works which
is true they say is China South Korea in
other countries have demonstrated it's
possible to slow the spread of the virus
and limit how many people are infected
at one time this will keep hospitals
from being overwhelmed with patients
said those who are sick can be treated
competently
and compassionately and this is already
apparently rearing its ugly head in New
York City where there's a shortage of
ICU beds and ventilators apparently
there are there messages going around
last night from from at least one person
that I'd heard of in a hospital who is
suggesting the medical ethics boards
were having to decide who to give a
ventilator a person who is elderly with
cancer or person who is young with
coronavirus no one knows for sure how
long social distancing will have to last
reduce the spread to near zero if South
Korea and China are appropriate
exemplars we'll need to stay apart now
for at least eight weeks and maybe more
trying to lock down Wuhan and other
cities and who may Provence January 23rd
today provincial officials are reporting
few or no cases of the virus just a few
days ago they closed the last of their
16 and makeshift emergency hospitals
restrictions are easing schools and
offices are slowly opening people are
beginning to go out and see other people
that timeline says Ezekiel Emanuel
suggest your kids are not going back to
school April 1st nor are you returning
to the officer catching a movie anytime
soon plan for social distancing at least
until mid or late may be thankful if it
eases off earlier now again that's sort
of what I suggested earlier that we are
talking about an eight week period here
of social distancing an eight week
period where you're working from home as
much as possible when can we expect that
Americans slowly emerge from their homes
like much about the novel virus say easy
kill Emanuel as well as these other
doctors we don't know for sure
a likely scenarios there will be a
subsequent wave of the disease that's
what happened in Denver in the flu
outbreak of the Spanish flu pandemic and
Toronto during the 2003 SARS outbreak
over the next few months South Korea
China other countries will generate some
relevant evidence to show how this might
play out
they say the reality is that influenza
bill and most cold viruses wane in the
summer but they do so in part because a
lot of people catch them in the winter
since we've never been infected with
this corona virus before there's no
acquired immunity so we don't know that
there will be a season or reprieve
although it is true that there has been
a seasonal reprieve in some of the more
equatorial countries that are that are
seeing the transmission of a corona
virus they say the irony of successful
social distancing is that fewer will
develop immunity which means that social
distancing 2.0 3.0 maybe even 4.0 will
likely have to occur they say the next
round of social distancing will be
activated more rapidly because officials
and the public will be more prepared and
should also be shorter because fewer
people are going to be likely to be
infected but it will still disrupt
people's lives and the economy will have
canceled conferences and sporting events
people will not frequent restaurants and
will not travel the service industry
will be severely curtailed it's going to
happen again and again so I think this
is probably true but
this does raise the question as to how
long Americans are going to undergo the
harshness of the of the current regime
which is basically everybody stay home
and never come out of your houses again
I don't think Americans are gonna live
with that for indefinite periods of time
if you tell people that eight weeks is
sort of the outer limit of that which is
sort of what Ezekiel Emanuel is saying
and then you say and here's our plan
beyond eight weeks I think people will
feel a lot more secure the markets will
feel a lot more secure so we'll talk in
just a second about exactly what that
policy would look like
internationally everybody is locking
down yeah I made the mistake yesterday
of suggesting that Denmark was not
locking down they've actually taken some
significant measures particularly the
last week and a half in order to lock
down in the same way that other
countries are locking down as well
Israel is now completely locking down
the government rolled out a new set of
restrictions on the Israeli population
Tuesday they have 427 coronavirus
patients in Israel they've not yet had a
death in Israel Bibi Netanyahu the prime
minister he said we started today using
digital technology that detects those
who come in contact with coronavirus
patients we'll send those people into
isolation these will be large numbers
isolation is not a recommendation in his
mandatory we will enforce it without
compromise he committed to dramatically
increasing the number of people tested
for coronavirus to the largest number
per capita in the world he says he
expects between 3,000 and 5,000 has to
be taken per day comparing Israel to
South Korea and this does bring up the
the policy that South Korea has actually
followed because South Korea has had a
different policy than a lot of these
other countries would France is now in
the middle of a complete lockdown
Emmanuel macron the president called for
citizens to restrict themselves from
taking unnecessary trips outside their
homes for at least two weeks so
everybody is sort of pursuing the lock
everything down routine that didn't
actually happen in South Korea the
reason being in South Korea they had
vast numbers of tes available right if
we had had vast numbers of tests
available it would made an enormous
enormous difference in just a second I'm
gonna explain how the South Korean
example worked and how it could work in
the future right after we let this thing
up in May then the new model is gonna
have to be obviously we have to have
more flexibility with our ICU beds but
maybe we can then apply the South Korean
model because we'll have the resources
we'll have the tests available well talk
about what South Korea actually did and
how their economy has continued to
actually operate in the middle of all
this as opposed to completely shutting
down the American economy which is
exactly what's going on right now which
is going to lead to some pretty dire
secuence again I think the American
people are willing to shut down the
economy temporarily we are not willing
to shut down the economy for 12 to 18
months and that is not something the
United States is gonna be able to
recover from at a certain point we all
become Ward's of the state and at that
point it's gonna be very difficult to
reverse back into the most powerful
economy in the history of the world it's
also going to be very difficult to
regain a lot of the economic freedoms
that we have traditionally relied upon
entrepreneurship will hit the skids
we'll get to all that in just a little
bit first let us talk about the fact
that even if your business is now
operating largely remotely that does not
alleviate your HR issues okay they just
have a lot of employees who aren't at
the office but you still have a bunch of
HR issues those HR issues it didn't stop
existing just because all your employees
went home in fact there are all sorts of
new regulations about what exactly your
employees can and cannot do
this is why you need HR specialists on
the job working for you and this is
where Bambi comes in BA MBE was created
specifically for small business you can
get a dedicated HR manager craft HR
policy maintain your compliance all for
just $99 a month and you may not be able
to afford right now hiring an entire HR
specialist for your team but you
certainly can afford ninety nine bucks a
month to make sure that you don't have
HR issues your dedicated HR manager is
available by phone email or real-time
chat from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees here today all for just 99
bucks a month month to month no hidden
fees you can cancel anytime you didn't
start your business because you want to
spend all your time on HR compliance let
Bambi help you get your free HR audit
today you can't afford to get this stuff
wrong like ever and certainly right now
go to Bambi comm slash Shapiro right now
to schedule your free HR audit that is
Bambi comm slash up hero spelled BA MBE
e-comm slash Shapiro and get that free
HR audit right now protect yourself from
legal liability that comes along with
screwing up your HR by actually not
scoring up your HR over at Bambi comm
slash up hearings that for 99 bucks a
month Amit has a pretty solid deal okay
so how does South Korea handle all of
this well according to an article from
the American Institute of Economic
Research there's an article by Peter
Earle over there talking about how South
Korea took a different tack than a lot
of other countries
he said South Korea has seen a steady
decrease in new coronavirus cases for
the latter half of last week the country
had the fourth most cases of coronavirus
in the world there were no geographic
quarantines enforced by armed guards
instead the sole focus was on widespread
testing and isolating the sick
after averaging over 500 new cases per
day back to the last week of February
between Friday and Sunday the daily
totals numbered 438 367 and 248
according to the Korea Center for
Disease Control how is it that without
deploying the military or imposing
widespread enforced quarantine the
spread of coronavirus in South Korea is
apparently slowing actually there's a
better question why should the US copy
China rather than South Korea the United
States is deep in the throes of an
election season at present and so
haughty and voting's of the Constitution
and Declaration of Independence are
occurrence of course talk is generally
cheap all the cheaper one coming from
the mouths of politicians South Korea is
operating in a freer way than China
South Korea is leveraging private
property rights to thwart the spread of
the virus building owners have been
posting and enforcing no masks no entry
signs drive-through testing stations
have been set up nationwide through
which individuals after a ten minute
test are notified within a few hours if
they're infected a voluntary self
diagnosis phone app was created in the
early stages of the pandemic living and
treatment centers were set up in a soft
quarantine spirit mostly South Koreans
are acting based on their experience of
the h1n1 pandemic in 2009 they are
washing their hands frequently making an
effort not to touch their faces wearing
masks and social distancing to the
extent possible
the high level of personal technology
and access in South Korea makes the
latter most eminently practicable given
the ubiquity of video telecommunications
and other such technologies there's this
columnist for a IAR says it's true that
certain aspects of South Korea's
handling of the outbreak nevertheless
infringes upon individual rights in
particular where privacy is concerned
because they're using camera
surveillance and tracking cell phone and
banking activities of people who may
have coronavirus but that's a hell of a
lot less restrictive then everybody go
home and stay home forever
so the the premise of the South Korean
government approach according to Vice
Health Minister Kim gang guilt gang lip
was quote without harming the principle
of a transparent and open society we
recommend a response system that blends
voluntary public participation with
creative applications of Advanced
Technology and South Korea has handled
this without shutting down their economy
in the same way that we are currently
shutting down our economy it also
demonstrates the foolishness of all of
the advice that you are getting not to
wear a face mask
early on there's a difference between
the medical-grade face masks that were
in short supply and are needed by
doctors and the and the face masks that
you wear when you go to the hospital you
know basically just a piece of cloth
with some with some loops for your ears
oh yeah that's not what we're talking
about when we say the doctors need
medical masks this
not the same types of masks South Korea
has been applying those masks in public
for a very long time
the reason is not because it's gonna
prevent you from getting coronavirus
it's because it's gonna prevent you from
transmitting coronavirus because the
orifice is most likely to generate the
germs on your nose in your mouth zeyneb
to fakie is a professor of information
science specializing in social effects
of technology as a piece of the New York
Times saying exactly this today saying -
why telling people they don't need masks
backfired as the pandemic rages on there
will be many difficulties for the public
says this columnist unfortunately the
top-down conversation around masks has
become a case study and how not to
communicate with the public
especially now that traditional
gatekeepers like media and health
authorities have much less control the
message became counterproductive may
have encouraged even more hoarding
because it seemed as though authorities
were shaping the message around managing
scarcity rather than confronting the
reality of the situation first many
health experts including the Surgeon
General told the public simultaneously
the masks weren't necessary for
protecting the general public and that
health care workers needed the dwindling
supply this contradiction obviously
confused the ordinary listener why is it
that health care workers in it but I
don't ii there were attempts to bolster
the first message that ordinary people
didn't need masks by telling people that
masks especially medical grade
respirator masks like the n95 needed
proper fitting that ordinary people
without such fitting wouldn't benefit
again that is deeply counterproductive
many people wash their hands wrong we
don't tell them not to bother washing
their hands and then of course masks
work maybe not perfectly and not also
the same degree but they do provide some
protection their use has always been
advised as part of the standard response
to being around infected people
especially for people who may be
vulnerable WH o officials wear masks
during their news briefings that was the
reason I bought a few in early January
been conducting research in Hong Kong
which has a lot of contacts in mainland
China and expected to go back they had
studied says this columnist and taught
about the sociology of pandemics and
knew from the Czar's experience in 2003
that health officials in many high-risk
Asian countries had advised wearing
masks and threw the masks don't work
perfectly that they don't replace
hand-washing and social distancing that
they work better if they fit properly
and surgical masks which are the
disposable type that I'm talking about
don't filter out small viral particles
the way medical grade masks do but even
surgical masks protect a bit more than
not wearing masks at all we know from
flu research that mask wearing can help
to create Ran's Mission rates along with
frequent hand-washing and social
distancing now that we're facing a
respirator masks shortage the federal
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention is reck
mending that surgical masks are an
acceptable alternative for healthcare
workers again obviously because some
protection even if imperfect is better
than none for that WH on CDC told the
public to wear masks if they were sick
so again like there are all these
conflicting messages here's the bottom
line moving forward after this thing
alleviates and people go back to work
here's Morgan Andy we're gonna need the
widespread availability of testing so
that you can get tested quickly and then
you can and then you can isolate fast we
are going to need people to continue
social distancing we are going to need
those who can telecommute and do
telehealth to do that we are going to
need people to wear masks that is going
to be something that we probably are
going to need these sort of long-term
policies are going to be useful
the South Korean strategy becomes viable
when those resources are available but
the South Korean strategy was not viable
and is not viable in the United States
because number one people don't have the
masks number two we don't actually have
the capacity at this point to give those
widespread tests but this is why the
government policy needs to be generated
right now toward making all the stuff
available right we need more ICU beds we
need widespread testing and then when we
get back to regular life the economy can
continue functioning again okay
meanwhile the United States government
is taking new measures the u.s. is
planning to swiftly turn back people
entering from Mexico illegally according
to the New York Times the Trump
administration plans to immediately turn
back all asylum seekers and other
foreigners attempting to enter the u.s.
from Mexico illegally saying the nation
cannot risk allowing the corona virus to
spread through detention facilities and
Border Patrol agents according to for
administration officials those
administration officials said ports of
entry would remain open to American
citizens green card holders and
foreigners with proper documentation
some foreigners would be blocked
including Europeans currently subject to
earlier travel restrictions imposed by
the administration points of entry will
also be open to commercial traffic but
border patrol agents are going to
immediately return anyone to Mexico who
attempts to cross the southwestern
border by the way we're also closing our
borders to Canada so stop calling this
racist because it simply is not
meanwhile the United States has reported
its 100th death we are now up to at
current count and again this is just at
the at the present time we're now up to
a hundred and fifteen deaths or so
somewhere in that neighborhood in the
United States we saw a jump in New York
last night 16 deaths in New York last
night
the Trump administration is also moving
to enlist more agencies in a
whole-of-government response to the
virus we'll get to that in just one
second first let's be real about this
roomy home for a while okay so now would
be a fantastic time so we're kind that
degree you've always wanted I mean
you're sitting at home what do you have
that is more important or better to do
than that you got some extra time on
your hands why not do something useful
and mitad lee it's hard to go back to
school while you are at work but right
now you're probably home and that's why
I recommend Ashford University right now
is a great time to enlist in the courses
you've always wanted to enlist in
Ashford University's online bachelor's
and master's degree programs allow you
to learn at your own pace
you can study wherever you are most
comfortable learning Ashford allows you
to take one course at a time being
enrolled in one class at Ashford means
you're considered a full-time student
the SAT GRE GMAT other standardized test
scores not required for enrolling at
Ashford and Ashford is fully accredited
by the W ASC senior college and
university Commission so get on the road
to earning your degree and making your
dream job a reality get that resume
ready guys because now is a great time
to get educated enroll now by going to
Ashford edu slash Ben that is Ashford
edu slash Ben has there ever been a
better time seriously to do this go
check out Ashford edu slash Ben's start
your degree today Ashford edu slash Ben
ok one get to more of the news plus we
have to get to what what we're gonna do
at the Chinese government ok the Chinese
government is responsible for this
everybody who keeps saying don't say boo
Han flu don't don't take home flu don't
say Chinese virus shut the hell up I
mean seriously it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous the Chinese government is
responsible for this no one's talking
about Chinese people nobody's talking
about being racist against Chinese
people stop with his absolute
politically correct garbage if you do
not look at the Chinese government as
the cause of all of this it's because
you're not looking closely enough or
because you wish not to look at that and
you're too busy and you're politically
correct bizarre universe to actually
look at the reality we'll get to that in
just a second first I hope you've had a
chance to see some of our new content we
started this week called all access live
over its daily where'd I come Jeremie
boring and I kicked off Monday evening
we talked to movies we talked a little
bit of religion and then Jeremy and
Michael Knowles followed up last night
we're doing episode the rest of the week
like every night this week at 8 p.m.
Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific you know it was
actually pretty fun shooting all access
live it was a little more relaxed than
our normal program we just sat around
and shot the bleep well we're all kind
of stuck in isolation right now it's
really important that we actually come
together as a community
I think these live streams with our
audience helped bring us together even
if it's through
computer make you feel a little about
less lonely it's less focused on
bringing you news and information more
about just hanging out with you at the
end of a long workday or a long day
sitting in isolation waiting for this
thing to end this show is actually
intended for all access members but
because like right now we all need a
little bit of help we accelerated the
launch and we opened it up to all of our
daily wire members for the time being so
please let us know if you like the show
actually and what you'd like to see more
or less of I know you want less Knowles
I get it already but remember we're
gonna get through this we're gonna be
stronger as a nation as a community when
we do so if you're round at like 8 p.m.
Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific tonight join
us on all axis live again over at daily
wire comm and you can watch the live
stream and join the chat we were always
trying to bring our community together
and bring you new information now's a
great time to join the club over at Daly
wire.com we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
all right so more on the federal
response so the the Trump administration
is now starting to activate various
branches of the federal government the
New York state government is pleading
for help from the Army Corps of
Engineers to quickly build hospitals
Oregon's governor repeatedly pressed the
Department of Health and Human Services
for hundreds of thousands of respirators
gallons gloves face shields goggles
president Trump is enlisting much of the
government and what the White House had
called for we saw whole-of-government
approach to the rampaging coronavirus he
says we're starting at the process now
presumably that should have started
weeks ago obviously and yes they're
gonna be heads that have to roll in the
federal government over the slow
response overall this yes the lack of
tests from January on is pretty much
unforgivable if South Korea could turn
out these tests why could not the United
States government the most powerful
force in the history of the world why
why is that not a reality why weren't
the tests available and that those are
serious questions that are gonna have to
be asked we're gonna have to ask why we
weren't spending the last few weeks
prepping the ICU beds that we all knew
we were gonna need but at least the
shift is happening apparently an
internal report from the DHS the
Department of Health and Human Services
has or HHS rather has concluded the
pandemic will last 18 months or longer
could include multiple waves of the
illnesses the virus will significant
will cause significant shortages for
government private sector individual US
consumers and coordinated by the federal
government a coordination by the feds
would be imperative according to the
document but a lot of these a lot of
these various agencies were not brought
into play until the last couple of days
hospital ships right now are at Port the
Department of Veterans Affairs a way to
request for help the veterans Department
has a surplus of beds and many of its
172 Hospital sensors a robust number of
special rooms for patients with
breathing and disorders although if the
media is pretending and those are gonna
be up to snuff in terms of the numbers
we need that is probably wrong the
sprawling system of emergency doctors
and nurses ready to be deployed by the
Department of Health and Human Services
the National Disaster medical system is
also still waiting for orders other than
to staff locations where passengers
offloaded from cruise ships are being
quarantined the Department of Defense
home to 1.3 million active duty troops
and a civilian and military
infrastructure that is made planning for
national emergencies almost an art form
has yet to be deployed to its fullest
capacities again all of this is
incredibly fluid all this is incredibly
fluid now the New York Times suggests
that this is a the the fault of the
Trump administration they points out the
President Obama despatched 3,000
American troops
Iberia to build hospitals and treatment
centers to help fight Ebola that's true
it's also a lot easier to figure out
where exactly you're gonna send your
troops when all you have to do is send
them into a foreign country and then ask
the federal and then ask the government
there where to send them presumably
we're gonna do the same thing here the
Pentagon opened a joint command
operation at a hotel in Liberia's
Capitol to coordinate the international
effort so that they're trying to say
that Obama did great job with Ebola
whereas we're doing a crappy job with
coronavirus these are not the same thing
at all okay an outbreak in a foreign
country that is a lot smaller than the
United States and where you don't have
to try and figure out which citizens to
protect and which ones not to protect a
lot less difficult than what the federal
government is trying right now defense
secretary Marquez percent on Tuesday the
Pentagon will make available to the
Department of Health and Human Services
up to five million and 95 masks which
can be used to help protect health
workers and vulnerable people against
the virus the first million are going to
be available immediately now why that
wasn't done weeks ago is beyond me the
Pentagon is also making available 2,000
ventilators for hospitals which is not
putting a serious dent in what is needed
at this point but bottom line is that it
is late but it is happening at least the
federal government is doing what it can
do at this point now meanwhile on the
local level Bill DeBlasio is fighting
with Andrew Cuomo Bill DeBlasio saying
maybe we need a whole of got we need an
entire shelter shelter in place order
one of the things that we have to be
careful of is letting the letting the
evidence lead us where we're supposed to
go in terms of actual public action
because San Francisco declared a
shelter-in-place order now every mayor
in the United States basically has an
incentive to double down on what is the
most restrictive possible thing to do
and so we have to determine whether that
it's actually useful whether it is not
useful there well there hasn't been much
of a debate so far as to what's useful
and what's not useful everybody just
snaps to okay we got to do something and
we got to do something significant and I
think that that's probably right in
terms of instinct but as time passes the
question is to whether you need to
actually tell people that social
distancing is not enough that it's not
enough to tell people not to go to
restaurants that we actually have to
force people to stay in their homes for
prolonged periods of time boom how that
lasts for eight weeks
honestly like just on a realistic level
it's gonna be very difficult to police
all this data and I do have to note that
the insanity of the fact that the New
York City government right now is
telling everybody that they may have to
shelter in place well the Brooklyn
district attorney Eric Gonzales
is publicly announcing that his office
will immediately stop prosecuting
low-level nonviolent offenses and and
we'll consider freeing jailed suspects
who are vulnerable to infection I don't
know how you simultaneously hold those
positions you're telling people you're
gonna prosecute them if they go open
their restaurant but if you decide to
break into the restaurant and steal cash
from the tillow you won't be prosecuted
how is that not a perverse incentive I
mean seriously this is insane how can
you have local governments announcing
that if you commit a crime it's gonna be
fine like the very least shut your face
dude even if you're not going to enforce
it you seriously want to say openly I
mean what is this the purge you want to
say openly to criminals guys have at it
we're not gonna prosecute anything in
New York implemented decades ago the
broken windows theory by James Q Wilson
which suggested that policing of
low-level crimes prevents the commission
of larger level crimes and that is true
it's a social science statistics prove
this so I guess now New York and
apparently Philadelphia as well they're
pursuing a policy of go break the
windows go break the windows we won't
prosecute you what do they think that's
gonna do to crime levels and by the way
do you really believe that young people
across the country are many of them are
um are impoverished are simply going to
sit at home without any sort of without
any sort of social life like they've
ever come up with a better policy fast
is all I'm saying because the policies
that are being pursued by local
governments are not workable these are
not workable in the long term they may
be workable for a period of time
law-abiding people will follow them but
we are now cracking down and all the
law-abiding people well telling all the
non law-abiding people that we're not
gonna crack down on them I have no idea
how that is possibly good policy it
makes no sense at all it makes no sense
at all again I'm not saying that we
shouldn't stay at home I'm staying at
home right everybody that like seriously
like we're in LA everybody's at home
it's a zombie apocalypse out there
there's no one on the roads and I think
that in the short term given the
resources available that is perfectly
appropriate but how can you at the same
time tell people that the cops are not
going to enforce the law Arion sane here
Brooklyn da spokesperson Orrantia nev
said it's just a bunch of low-level
offenses basically anything where
there's no kind of violence and no
requirements to see a judge really the
idea is just to decrease the number of
people in the system are you insane
like what in the world so apparently we
are now just going to apparently we're
now just going to release criminals into
the wild now it's not gonna have any
downside great stuff great great stuff
yeah again Philadelphia police are doing
the same thing
they're stopping low-level arrests to
prevent jail crowding jail overcrowding
nothing like incentivizing criminality
to make everybody's life better in the
midst of a pandemic it meanwhile there's
all this ridiculous controversy over
what we label this thing yeah President
Trump suggested openly the other day
that this is the Chinese virus and he
was smacked for it and President Trump
was asked about this yesterday said yeah
I'm gonna continue to call it the
Chinese menace cuz the Chinese
government's responsible for all of this
criticize you for using the phrase
Chinese virus how do you feel about you
guys to continue using that phrase well
China was putting out information which
was false that our military gave this to
them that was false and rather than
having an argument I said I have to call
it where it came from it did come from
China so I think it's a very accurate
term but no I didn't appreciate the fact
that China was saying that our military
gave it to them our military did not
give give it anybody I don't know I
think saying that our military gave it
to them creates a stigma correct
accurate win for President Trump this is
absolutely correct okay can we just be
frank about this the Chinese government
is responsible for this they're
responsible for this at every level the
Chinese government actively sought to
silence people who are talking about the
corona virus they actively tried to
arrest people they forced them to recant
true statements about coronavirus not
only that according to the UK The Sunday
Times Chinese scientists destroyed proof
of the virus in December according to
The Times of The Times of London Chinese
laboratories identified a mystery virus
as a highly infectious new pathogen by
late December last year they were
ordered to stop test destroy samples and
suppress the news a Chinese media outlet
has revealed a Regional Health official
in Wuhan center of the outbreak demanded
the destruction of the lab samples that
established the cause of unexplained
viral pneumonia on January 1st China did
not acknowledge there was human to human
transmission until more than three weeks
later the details revelations by kicks
in global a respected independent
publication provide the clearest
evidence yet of the scale of the
cover-up in the crucial early weeks when
the opportunity was lost to control the
outbreak by the way the WHL bought this
hook line & sinker the World Health
Organization
suggested in middle of January the
corona virus is not a threat because
they had been formed of that by the
Chinese government
hey the Chinese government is
responsible for this they're responsible
for it from beginning to end the Chinese
government attempted actively to silence
doctors warning others about the disease
according to the Washington Post as word
of a mysterious virus mounted Li wen
Liang shared suspicions in a private
chat with his fellow medical school
graduates the doctors had seven people
seem to have contracted SARS the
respiratory illness from China that was
sent to two dozen countries left
hundreds dead in the early 2000s he
urged people to be careful Leigha and
seven other doctors were quickly
summoned by Chinese authorities for
propagating rumors about SARS like cases
in the area the warnings were pression
soon health officials worldwide would be
scrambling to combat a novel virus with
the striking genetic resemblance to SARS
as Jim Garrity says at national review
Chinese authorities spent January deny
it could spread between humans something
doctors had known was happening since
late December now we know that were
destroying the proof and went ahead with
a Chinese Lunar New Year banquet
involving tens of thousands of families
in Wuhan doctors say Mohan people who
had no connection to the quinine market
were among the first showing the
symptoms so the Chinese authorities
understood human-to-human transition was
happening right from the very outset
even by the Chinese government's own
accounts of events President Xi Jinping
knew about the disease for two weeks
before making any public comments about
it under fire for its response to the
coronavirus epidemic according to the
New York Times
China's authoritarian government appears
to be pushing a new account of events
that presents President Xi Jinping as
taking early action to fight the
outbreak that has convulsed the country
but in doing so the authorities have
acknowledged for the first time that mr.
ji was aware of the epidemic and
involved in the response nearly two
weeks before he first spoke publicly
about it and while people at the
epicenter were still downplaying the
dangers according to The Wall Street
Journal the Chinese government let some
5 million people leave Wuhan without
screening Chinese medical authorities
also banned staff from discussing the
disease in public or via text or images
8 days after this ban went in place a
nurse in one of these departments
started to feel sick was confirmed she
was infected by coronavirus by early
March three doctors at this particular
Hospital had died from the infection
even today Chinese citizens who
criticize the government are disappeared
okay the WeChat is currently banning
Chinese Americans for talking about Hong
Kong I mean this
this is insane the Chinese government
announced yesterday it's going to expel
American journalists according to mark
Tracy Edward Wang and Lara Jakes in a
sharp escalation of tensions between the
two superpowers China announced on
Tuesday would expel American journalists
working for the New York Times The Wall
Street Journal in The Washington Post it
also demanded that those outlets as well
as The Voice of America and Time
magazine provide the Chinese government
with detailed information about their
operations the announcement was made by
China's Ministry of Foreign Affairs
they're blaming it on America booting
out Chinese propagandists who've been
claiming that America's military was
behind this whole thing
but in reality is it possible that China
is still covering this thing up of
course that's highly possible is that
China is still covering this thing up so
I don't want to hear any of this crap
from Stephen Colbert about how it's
racist to call this the Chinese virus it
is the Chinese government virus and
furthermore once this abates and once
things start to go back to normal the
Trump administration should tell the
Chinese government that the travel ban
on Chinese citizens moving to and from
the United States and on American
citizens moving to and from China should
continue until the Chinese authoritarian
government shuts down on these wet
markets and the web markets are these
animal markets or people are eating
civets real eating bats people eating
snakes okay this is now been responsible
for swine flu bird flu SARS h1n1 and
this okay so we have seen virus after
virus after virus emanating from these
wet markets in China and the Chinese
authoritarianism a bee kill you
depending on what you say about the
government or what you say about
coronavirus they won't shut down these
markets how is it that the international
community is willing to allow a global
pandemic to take place on its watch and
the entire world economy does shudder to
a screeching halt I mean this is it's
unbelievable the entire world economy is
now stopped dead like completely stopped
dead all because China would not shut
down the practice of people eating
fricking bats at the local markets
there's been a problem for four decades
okay this is nothing new
going over back to the 1950s there was
an Asian flu it was literally called the
Asian flu and Asian flu outbreak in the
late 1950s and it came from these animal
markets the Chinese government is an
authoritarian government at the very
least they should be outlawing these
markets it should be prosecuting people
who are selling exotic animals for
people to eat this is written and by the
way that's not cultural races
in any way don't eat the frickin bats
you idiots I mean seriously how many
lives have been saved if the Chinese
government had spent one ounce of its
authoritarianism cracking down on
perfectly illegal activity or activity
that ought to be illegal like eating the
local wildlife I mean this is this is
insane
the Trump administration the rest of the
world should be on board for this -
honestly like can we all afford to do
this happen once every four or five
years because that's the future the
future is that once every four or five
years once every ten years there will be
another virus emanating from China which
has yet to shut down this stuff and then
has covered it up in authoritarian
fashion and they unleash it on an
unsuspecting global community and then
all of the people in the media go oh
it's so racist it's so epically
unpalatable to say this is the Chinese
virus it has nothing to do with the skin
color of the people or the location or
the ethnicity of the people who are
saying this stuff it has to do with the
Chinese communist authoritarian
government which is now unleashed for
the one millionth time a virus on the
rest of the world because they will not
shut down what is obviously disgusting
activity I'm sorry it is disgusting PETA
civet okay it's gross beyond being gross
I don't care you can do whatever is
gross to your liking okay I'm a
libertarian on this stuff except if
there are externalities and it turns out
you eating a civet you eating a penguin
has some pretty significant
externalities you think we're gonna lose
ten trillion dollars in this economy
because of this routine seriously there
better be some consequences to the
Chinese government after all of this I
mean the stock market again is down
below 20,000 this is this is wild and
our chief focus is Stephen Colbert
sitting by his fireside and his nicely
apportioned mansion talking about how
terrible it is to label this the Chinese
virus give me a freakin break
Steve minuchin the Treasury secretary is
warning that this virus could yield a
20% jobless rate if we don't spend
trillions of dollars is that worth not
punishing the Chinese government and
forcing them to shut down these markets
at the very least I mean forget I'm not
even saying that we ought to force the
Chinese government to openness I'm not
even saying that we ought to root for
the overthrow of the Chinese communist
regime which by the way we should I mean
it's an evil evil regime forget about
what they do with it with the civet this
is a regime that has overseen the forced
sterilization of presumably tens of
millions of women over the course of the
last 30 years I mean it's an evil
government it is it is an evil
government just as evil as the Soviet
Union just nobody talks about it I mean
literally
is evil the Great Leap Forward killed
far more people than the halle the
Holodomor the the murder of millions in
Ukraine by the Stalin regime this is an
evil regime and we've been treating with
kid gloves for years we should not be
but put that aside even if you're just
talking about shutting down these these
ridiculous eating the exotic animals
markets we are now going to see we're
gonna go from a 3.5 unemployment rate in
this country to a 20% unemployment rate
in this country because China refused to
crack down on people eating eating wild
animals seriously
here is Treasury secretary Steve
minuchin apparently he says that the
jobless rate could hit 20 percent
according to CNBC I'm told that in those
meetings that the Treasury secretary
said that if Congress does not pass this
package that unemployment could touch 20
percent trying to highlight the dire
consequences that could await this
country if Congress does not actually
move forward this package of
unprecedented proportions that would
deliver that money directly to Americans
okay so the the measures that are
currently being taken by the federal
government by the way include things
like keeping that commercial paper
window open which is a good thing there
they're talking about floating cash to
people's that they can make rent for the
next couple of months there's been some
talk Andrew Ross Sorkin has a piece in
The New York Times today suggesting that
effectively the the government float
zero interest loans for the next five
years repayable to businesses that need
them over the next few months and again
all of this I think should be off the
table if it were not the government that
we're imposing the lock down in the
first place the government is imposing
the lock down in the first place that
means that these businesses normally the
answer is like in 2007-2008 businesses
that were poorly run in made bad
decisions and then the and then they're
hit by a down turning economy that is
not the result of an external shock or
an internal shock directed by government
if those businesses don't deserve a
bailout but if you are talking about the
federal government forcibly shutting
down businesses that is a different
story so even that distinguishes between
businesses like the airline business and
there's a good case we made the airlines
should not actually be bailed out that
we should be bailing out their employees
because the airlines have been using
their money for stock buybacks because
the airlines should have banked up
enough cash to at least survive even if
it means furloughing their employees for
the foreseeable future and then we
should compensate the employee
but if you're talking about keeping
business afloat for a couple of months
if you're talking about making sure that
basically frees the economy in place for
a couple of months as long as there's an
end date to that then all possibilities
are sort of on the table but we should
examine the consequences of those
policies the danger of course to
open-ended loans like that there's a lot
of people who are never gonna repay
those loans there there is some
winnowing that is going to happen in
this economy this is gonna change the
way people live in particularly
significant ways even when this ends the
movie industry is gonna take a hit the
entertainment industry's gonna take a
hit so you really want the government
floating loans to industries that are
gonna take a permanent hit over the
course of time because our way of life
just radically changed that is unclear
how people earn back their money at this
point perhaps the best way to do it
Sorkin suggests that basically you
should go to the banks and then you
should say to the banks we're gonna back
whatever loans you choose to give and
and that may be the best way to do it
because the banks actually have an
actuarial interest in only giving out
loans that will eventually be repaid as
opposed to the federal government which
has an interest in handing out free cash
helicopter cash to everybody okay so the
bottom line here is that we don't know
where any of this is going ones and you
are seeing local restaurants shut down
you're seeing people hurt we're going to
have to figure out in pretty short order
what the trajectory of this thing is
greatest hope by May this thing starts
to wane by May people start going back
to if not normal something slightly
resembling normal it's gonna change our
way of life particularly in small spaces
I think that the concert industry is
gonna have a rough time I think a lot of
local restaurants gonna have a rough
time everything may translate over to
in-room dining
you know delivery it may transfer over
to bigger restaurants with more space
that people can be spaced out a little
bit more but with all of that said we
are going to have to figure out what the
second step here is because it is just
not sustainable for everybody to be
locked in their homes for six 12 18
months it's not sustainable
the economy cannot take it because at a
certain point what who's gonna buy the
debt who's gonna buy the bonds at a
certain point the federal government's
gonna have to just under inflating the
currency at which point everybody who
has any money is worth nothing so it's
very it's very you know bottom line is
that the federal government has to take
measures to keep the economy running for
the moment but that should be temporary
and we should have a plan for what
happens next okay meanwhile in other
news Joe Biden cleaned up last night so
there were some primaries
yesterday Joe Biden won primaries in
Florida Illinois and Arizona he did it
easily
he percentages for him were
extraordinarily high that is not a big
shock the turnout was actually on pace
to surpass the 2016 primary in places
like Arizona which is kind of shocking
given the fact that pretty much
everybody is supposed to be in lockdown
in Maricopa County which included
Phoenix more than 40,000 people voted in
person
on Tuesday compared to 35,000 there in
2016 much of Sanders support has come
from young voters that didn't play out
in Arizona it didn't play out in Florida
he just got skunked in Florida
both Florida and Arizona surpassing the
turnout honestly it was irresponsible to
hold these primaries if you are
seriously concerned about the about the
corona virus it's irresponsible to have
the huge numbers of people in line Biden
of course won Illinois with big big
numbers so in a time of panic Joe Biden
who's as I've said mashed potatoes and
chicken soup that guy is is probably the
the I mean this is helping Biden versus
Bernie obviously bernie is a
destabilizing force in a time that
requires stability and it just
demonstrates how crazy bernie is the
yesterday Bernie suggested that any
business receiving aid at all should
receive the the government should own a
part of it this is nuts by the way it is
the government that is causing the
economic downturn right now it is it's
the government that is telling everybody
to go home and I'm not saying they're
wrong to do it I'm just saying that for
the government to say to everybody stay
home we're going to destroy your
business also we're gonna give you the
loans and also we're gonna own your
business is totally wild
that's wild I mean that's just a thug
tactic by the government that's
basically nationalization by back to
when Bernie Sanders is all for it here's
Bernie being a nut yesterday we must
make sure that companies they get
bailouts are required to sell equity to
the government and put workers on their
board of directors this is this is crazy
and the government is gonna is going to
force companies into bankruptcy which is
what is happening right now and then is
going to bail them out for a share of
the company and that's it's not even I
mean that that's that's crazy sounds
because it is the government that is
telling people to stay home right now
because there are a lot of companies
where if they were not told to stay home
right now people would be at work right
people would continue to operate because
the the businesses would have to make a
very tough decision between how much
exposure can we take is
business in terms of people being out
there and also laying off every employee
we have I mean there are hotel chains
that laid off tens of thousands of
people yesterday the unemployment rate
on this thing is gonna skyrocket so
adding the additional threat which is if
you take a loan from the federal who's
gonna take a loan from the federal
government under those circumstances
seriously
you thinking if my business is starting
to have a rough time then I am then
going to take a loan from the federal
government I'd rather go bankrupt
seriously
then take a loan from the federal
government that lets the federal
government run my business how's that
another first this is why this guy is
losing all the primaries who should be
losing all the primaries Joe Biden
yesterday appealed to Bernie Sanders
supporters he's trying to bring these
Sanders supporters inside the tent some
twenty percent of Democrats our Sanders
supporters most of the huge number of
them like forty percent of those people
say they won't vote for Joe Biden
because they don't think he's radical
enough which by the way is kind of crazy
cuz Joe Biden is very much on the Left
here is Joe Biden trying to appeal to
Bernie supporters senator Sanders and I
may disagree on tactics but we share a
common vision for the need to provide
affordable health care for all Americans
reduce income inequity that has risen so
drastically to tackling the existential
threat of our time climate change
senator Sanders and his supporters have
brought a remarkable passion and
tenacity to all of these issues and
together they have shifted the
fundamental conversation in this country
so let me say especially to the young
voters who have been inspired by senator
Sanders I hear you I know it's at stake
I know what we have to do our goal is a
campaign and my goal is a candidate for
president is to unify this party and
then to unify the nation yeah good luck
good luck with that the Bernie
supporters gonna have no part of this by
the way Joe Biden did finish the speech
in a very odd note he apparent enough to
know whether the camera was on or off
and so I just stood there awkwardly as
his wife came to usher him off the stage
which is always a great look here's what
that looked like
thank you all for mr. Smith he's just
stand-in there now just stand-in there
and standing there and there is dr. Joe
and then she's like they go there and
then there's just more awkwardness okay
like somebody at some point should have
turned off the camera maybe that's not
Biden's fault totally but he's just
standing there look what's going on like
seriously
speaking of all of this Bernie Sanders
still is not dropped out he's saying
he's reconsidering his campaign that of
course is the appropriate action at this
time Claire McCaskill former senator
from Missouri she says yeah it is long
past time for Bernie Sanders to drop out
I think the conversation is going to
quickly turn to how and when does Bernie
Sanders unite the Democratic Party
I predict that just like in Michigan and
Mississippi and Missouri we're gonna see
every county in Florida go for Joe Biden
every county in Arizona
go for Joe Biden and every County in
Illinois go for Joe Biden he's going to
end up netting a big number of Delegates
after tonight and so I think it is time
and well this is the end of Bernie
Sanders's campaign but it is not the end
of Bernie Sanders his impact because
what will Joe Biden have to give the
Sanders supporters in order to get them
back in the tent a lot of those people
are not gonna show up to vote they are
young they are motivated and they are
really really far on the left so how
many of them are gonna stick around for
Joe Biden Joe is gonna have to pick
somebody who is somewhat radical for his
VP or he's gonna risk losing all of the
Sanders supporters honestly if Biden
were smart what he would probably do at
this point is even though he hates
Sanders and thinks that he's a radical
kook which he is Biden should probably
offer Sanders some sort of
administration post and that's probably
something that he should do if he wants
to unify the party but if Biden hopes
that the Sanders people are just gonna
come around that that is not going to
happen
all righty we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content all your latest updates we'll be
back here tomorrow with all of your
latest updates stick with us over at
Daley wary of all sorts of great content
to get you through this unbelievably
trying time we're all here guys we're in
it together apart so we will use the
Internet to connect with one another I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike foramina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen